un bras cassé ou une entorse ces petits
ukrainiens se sont blessés lors d'
accidents de la vie quotidienne
j'étais sur l'air de jeu j'ai trébuché
et je suis tombé dans le sable hier
j'étais à l'école en train de jouer je
suis tombé je me suis cassé la main ces
patients sont en convalescence pour les
protéger au maximum du conflit qui fait
rage dehors les médecins ont installé
leur chambre ici dans l'abri anti
aériens de l'hôpital
pour ses enfants ce n'est pas bon d'être
déplacé de se lever du lit de devoir
descendre quand les sirènes se déclenche
c'est mieux qu'ils restent ici au calme
c'est dans leur lit
l'emplacement de l'hôpital est tenu
secret par sécurité dans l'abri il y
aussi le matériel nécessaire pour
soigner de nouveaux patients en urgence
il y a beaucoup de bombardements ici
nous nous tenons prêts jour et nuit à
accueillir des enfants blessés
depuis le début de la guerre nous avons
reçu 30 enfants et la plupart d'entre
eux étaient gravement touchés
pour les enfants le temps est long dans
les sous-sols de l'hôpital je sais ma
main va mieux je suis très content
mais les sourires reviennent lorsque
l'un d'entre eux peut enfin rentrer chez
lui